[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild bei einer erwachsenen Frau kann man
erstmal davon ausgehen dass sie
freiwillig gegangen ist und gleichzeitig
war aber auch klar bei dem Gespräch mit
der Mutter ja dass sie vom schlimmsten
ausgeht sogar weiter noch dass sie
eigentlich schon gesagt hat meine
Tochter ist tot ich möchte nur die
Bestätigung haben das war damals Ihr
Anlass sich auch öffentlich an den
mutmaßlichen Mörder zu wenden und ich
weiß wie mich das damals bewegt hat weil
ich immer das Gefühl hatte man muss ihr
Hoffnung zusprechen man muss hier
irgendwie sagen hey es kann doch immer
noch alles gut ausgehen aber das war gar
nicht der Antrieb der Mutter das ist die
Stimme meines Kollegen Daniel Böcking im
Herbst des Jahres 2000 bekommt er es mit
einem mysteriösen vermissten Fall zu tun
fast 20 Jahre später steht er noch
einmal im Kontakt mit der Familie aber
der Fall ist noch immer ungelöst und bis
heute gibt es nicht mal eine Leiche aber
das ist nicht das einzig rätselhafte an
dieser Geschichte und diese Geschichte
wollen wir euch heute erzählen ich bin
Mirko Kasim mir und mein Name ist Stefan
Netzeband hallo die Frau über die wir
sprechen heißt Inka köntkes sie
verschwindet am 10 August 2000 auf dem
Weg zur Arbeit Inka köntkes will ihren
Doktor in Biologie machen sie jobt an
der Medizinischen Hochschule in Hannover
und ist damals 29 Jahre alt inka ist 9
Jahre zuvor von Hamburg nach Hannover
gezogen nur sech Wochen vor ihrem
Verschwinden hat sie ihre große Liebe
geheiratet Mark er ist etwa ein Jahr
jünger und ebenfalls doktorant die
beiden wohnen zusammen in der
bronsartstraße im bürgerlichen Stadtteil
List am Morgen des 10 August 2000 gegen
8 Uhr macht sich Inker auf den Weg zur
Arbeit an der Medizinischen Hochschule
Hannover in der Stadt nutzen übrigens
alle nur die Abkürzung mhh sie nimmt
dafür wie immer ihr Damenfahrrad und
fährt durch den Stadtwald
Eilenriede aber sie kommt weder tagsüber
auf der Arbeit an noch abends wieder zu
Hause zum letzten Mal wird Inka an der
Rut und Klaus balsenbrücke gesehen die
von allen nur schneckenbrücke genannt
wird sie führt mitten im Wald über den
meerspurigen
Messeschnellweg zwischendurch hat Inka
sich wahrscheinlich Verfahren
normalerweise braucht man für ihren Weg
gut 20 Minuten aber Inka die ja um 8 Uhr
losgefahren ist fragt noch gegen 8:30
Uhr jemanden im Wald nach dem Weg man
kann sich in der allen red sehr gut
verlaufen oder Verfahren das kann ich
aus eigen Anschauung übrigens sagen ich
habe viele Jahre lang in Hannover gelebt
und die erste Zeit davon nur 10
Fahrradminuten von Inker köntkes Wohnung
in der List entfernt damit wir uns in
diesem Fall zurecht finden hier mal ein
paar informative Sätze über diesen
Stadtwald aus dem Stadtführer Mirko die
Eilenriede mit rund 640 hekta verfügt
Hannover über einen der größten Wälder
Europas im Herzen einer Großstadt selbst
der h parark in London kann da nicht
mithalten die grüne Lunge zieht sich
größtenteils zentrumsnah durch den
östlichen Teil der leineestadt mit einem
komfortablen Wegenetz und hunderten von
Ruhebänken mit Teichen Liegewiesen
Kinderspielplätzen und Waldgaststätten
erfüllt die Eilenriede viele Bedürfnisse
der nach Erholung suchenden Bürgerinnen
und Bürger seit über 600 Jahren ist der
Wald in städtischem Besitz im 19
Jahrhundert wandelte sich der Nutzwald
zu einem
Naherholungsgebiet auf ihrer längsten
Achse von Nord nach Süd misst die allen
redegut 6 km und viele Weggabelungen
gleichen sich Inker köntkes weg lässt
sich etwa so rekonstruieren er führt von
der bronsatstraße zunächst durch die
belebte zellerstraße im Stadtteil List
bis zum Beginn des Stadtwaldes wer es
grün mag verlässt dann die Straßen und
fähr FT in Höhe der Villa Seligmann in
den Wald je nach Streckenführung fährt
man an der soenannten Wilhelm buschwiese
vorbei radelt dann ab dem zo Hannover
ein Stück lang auf der Adenauer Allee
und kreuzt auf Höhe des Kongresszentrums
den Messeschnellweg das ist die schon
erwähnte schneckenbrücke nach einer
letzten kurzen Etappe durch den Wald
führt der Weg schließlich durch den
Stadtteil klefeld direkt zur Klinik und
nun die Frage an dich Stefan so als
exhannoveraner was bedeutet das denn für
den Fall tja zusammen mit der
zeugensichtung an der Brücke bedeutet
das schon mal dass Inka selbst wenn Sie
sich vorher Verfahren haben sollte bald
am Ziel war sie kann um die Uhrzeit also
etwa 8:30 Uhr auf einem so regelmäßig
genutzten Wegabschnitt eigentlich auch
nicht irgendwie weiß nicht gestürzt sein
ohne dass es bald jemandem auffällt
anderen Fahrradfahrern z.B auch
irgendeine dramatische Entführung auf
dieser Achse hätte eigentlich schnell
bemerkt werden müssen man kann also
davon ausgehen dass Inka sozusagen
freiwillig verschwunden ist die Polizei
findet auf jeden Fall keine
verbrechensspuren aber ihr Mann und ihre
Eltern in Hamburg machen sich große
Sorgen zumal Inka ohne irgendwelche
Klamotten oder gar Reisegepäck
verschwunden ist und auch auf ihrem
Konto tut sich nichts mehr der Fall
dringt an die Öffentlichkeit hier die
kurze Meldung in der Bild am Sonntag vom
20 August
2000 Studentin vermisst Hannover in der
expostadt wird seit 11 Tagen die
Studentin Inka köntkes vermisst die
biologiedoktorandin war mit dem Fahrrad
zur Arbeit gefahren kam dort aber nie an
die Suche der Polizei blieb bislang
erfolglos diese Meldung erscheint mit
einem Foto von ink einer blonden
jungenfrau mit frechen Augen und einem
ansteckenden Lächeln mit einem Foto
sucht inkers Familie auch auf
Steckbriefen in der Eilenriede nach ihr
der Text geht so Inka köntkes wird seit
dem
10.08.2008 Uhr vermisst sie war auf dem
Weg zur Medizinischen Hochschule
Hannover der Weg führt sie mit dem
Fahrrad von der bronzartstraße in List
durch die Eilenriede über den
Messeschnellweg weiter durch die
Schrebergärten von Groß Buchholz zur
medizinischen Hochschule inka köntkes
ist 1,69 m groß hat dunkelblonde
schulterlange Haare und blaue Augen sie
ist mit einer dunkelblauen Jacke die auf
völlige weiße steppnäte hat unterwegs
sie trägt eine helle Jeans und schwarze
Pumps die mit bunten Stickereien
verziert sind außerdem hat sie eine
schwarze Umhängetasche ca 30 x 30 cm
groß aus Kunststoffgewebe bei sich das
Damenfahrrad Marke Pegasus ist
silbergrau mit schwarzem Gelsattel
Wochen ziehen ins Land und Jahre mehrere
Male gibt es Spuren ins Nichts mal
wollen bekannte sie in in einer anderen
Stadt gesehen haben mal behauptet ein
Unbekannter telefonisch bei der Polizei
ich habe Inka aber Inka taucht nie
wieder auf es wird kein Täter ermittelt
es gibt keine Leiche Werbung Mo es gibt
Neuigkeiten aus dem Hause haer ich werde
jetzt Taucherin denn ich habe mir die
letzten Tage so viele tauchdokus und
Filme angeguckt ich kann dir z.B zwei
auf Netflix empfehlen einmal die
eistaucherin und der tiefste Atemzug es
geht ums Freitauchen das ist so verrückt
also wirklich ich kann euch nur
empfehlen das unbedingt euch anzugucken
und auch dir lieber Mirko okay klingt
auf jeden Fall mega spannend und ich bin
ja selber ein großer tauchfan und auch
ein großer Fan vom Meer natürlich aber
Tony ich glaube du streamst ja eh immer
übers Internet oder yes ich bin ja viel
am Pendeln zwischen Hamburg und Berlin
und das erste was dann im Zug passiert
ist das Smartphone wird gezückt um
Fernsehen zu gucken und ihr könnt das
auch mit o2 könnt ihr TV ganz einfach
über das Internet schauen egal ob auf
dem Fernseher Tablet oder Smartphone
ganz egal wo ihr seid auf o2 TV findet
ihr über 130 tvsender in HD und falls
man gerade mal irgendwas anderes vorhat
ja dann kann man bis zu 100 Stunden an
Livesendungen Serien und so weiter
einfach aufnehmen oder Filme anhalten
und später weiterschauen genau z.B wenn
gerade mal wieder eine Ellen lange
bahndurchsage kommt was auch richtig
cool ist an diesem Angebot A2 TV
funktioniert auf bis zu vier
verschiedenen Geräten gleichzeitig und
das nicht nur zu Hause sondern auch
unterwegs und das beste o2 TV gibt es
jetzt auch inklusive Netflix also Bucht
jetzt o2 t für günstige 9,99 € im Monat
undterhalte dazu 12 Monate Netflix
geschenkt geh dafür auf
o2de/gto/tatort also
2.de/goto/tat und sichert euch mit o2 TV
und dem Netflix standardabo mit Werbung
das Beste aus live Fernsehen und
Streaming als Paket genau alle Infos und
den link zum Angebot findet ihr
natürlich auch noch mal in den Show
nototes A2 can do Werbung Ende bei Bild
Hamburg kümmert sich Daniel Böcking um
den Fall er ist damals noch ganz neu und
trifft sich mit Inkas Mutter Brigitte
ich war noch nicht mal Redakteur ich war
volontaär damals in der polizeiredaktion
von Bild Hamburg und tatsächlich
erinnere ich mich noch an das Gespräch
weil mich das damals sehr berührt hat
also zum einen war es ein bisschen
außergewöhnlich weil Inka halt schon alt
war sie war volljährig und deswegen war
es auch nicht der klassische vermissten
Fall wenn ein Kind verschwunden ist und
ganz Deutschland den Atem anhält bei
einer erwachsenen Frau kann man erstmal
davon ausgehen dass sie freiwillig
gegangen ist und gleichzeitig war aber
auch klar bei dem Gespräch mit der
Mutter ja dass sie vom schlimmsten
ausgeht sogar weiter noch dass sie
eigentlich schon gesagt hat meine
Tochter ist tot ich möchte nur die
Bestätigung haben das war damals Ihr
Anlass sich auch öffentlich an den
mutmaßlichen Mörder zu wenden und ich WE
weiß wie mich das damals bewegt hat weil
ich immer das Gefühl hatte man muss ihr
Hoffnung zusprechen man muss i irgendwie
sagen hey es kann doch immer noch alles
gut ausgehen aber das war gar nicht der
Antrieb der Mutter sie war schon soweit
dass sie gesagt hat ja es ist was
grausames passiert und es ist furchtbar
aber diese Ungewissheit das ist dazu
geeignet dass ich daran zerbreche und
deswegen möchte ich gerne zumindest
Klarheit haben das ist das einzige was
ich mir noch Wünsche und hier sind
Auszüge aus dem Artikel den Daniel
damals geschrieben hat Mörder wo hast du
meine Tochter vergraben vor 40 Tagen
verschwand die 29-Jährige Biologin Inka
im Wald ihre Mutter glaubt an ein
Verbrechen verzweifelt fragt sie Mörder
wo hast du meine Tochter vergraben mein
Kind zu verlieren ist das
schmerzhafteste was mir wiederfahren ist
aber ein Leben lang nach meiner Inka zu
suchen ist noch ungleich schmerzhafter
es ist geeignet daran zu zerbrechen
Zeilen einer verzweifelten Mutter die
spürt dass Ihr Kind getötet wurde ein
Brief adressiert an den unbekannten
Mörder jetzt mit diesen geschriebenen
Worten hat sie Kontakt aufgenommen sie
fragt wo hast du meine Tochter vergraben
Brigit g 56 aus ralstedt hat die
Hoffnung aufgegeben ihre Tochter Inka
lebend wiederzusehen mein Kopf sagt mir
zwar dass noch alles offen ist sagt die
Krankenschwester leise sie schluckt
atmet tief durch aber tief im Herzen
fühle ich es
inka ist tot tränen schießen in ihre
Augen die Hände der zierlichen Frau
Zittern der Schmerz ist zu groß im Juni
heiratete Inka den Doktoranten Mark K 28
er hat mittlerweile gemeinsam mit der
Familie 20 000 Mark Belohnung ausgesetzt
soweit der Artikel ein dreiviertel Jahr
danach gibt es noch immer keine Spur von
Inka Daniel Böcking trifft Mutter
Brigitte g wieder denn Ende Mai 2001
soll es eine fernsehfhandung geben die
Mutter von Inka war auch sehr gläubig
und ist es bis heute das weiß ich auch
kann auch gerne gleich kurz erzählen
warum ich das noch weiß das hat damals
ich glaube in meinen Augen eine
überschaubare Rolle gespielt ich habe
den Text noch mal gelesen den ich damals
geschrieben habe da steht auch drin dass
die Mutter wieder und wieder sagte dass
der Glaube ihr die Kraft gibt und jetzt
so im Nachhinein gerade über all die
Jahre hinweg glaube ich dass ohne diesen
starken Glauben so eine Situation gar
nicht auszuhalten wäre dass man seine
Tochter sucht dass man davon ausgeht
dass sie tot ist aber dass es überhaupt
kein Hinweis auf Gewissheit gibt dass
die Polizei die Arbeit einstellt dass
alles beendet wird ich find es
wahnsinnig beeindruckend dass die Mutter
von Inka es geschafft hat so
abzuschließen auch den schlussstich zu
ziehen und was mich damals sehr
beeindruckt hat ist sie hat auch in
ihrem Schreiben an den mutmaßlichen
Mörder niemals nach Rache oder nach
Strafe oder sowas geschrieen sondern ich
glaube sie hat es sehr sehr ehrlich
damals gemeint dass sie da schon gesagt
hat mir geht es nicht um Strafverfolgung
sie möchte diese Gewissheit haben es
liegt nicht an ihr zu strafen und auch
das ist natürlich ein sehr christlicher
Ansatz zu sagen dass jetzt nicht an ihr
liegt Rache zu fordern oder was auch
immer oder Wut mit reinzubringen sondern
vor allem dass sie eine Chance hat das
für sich persönlich zu verarbeiten Bild
Hamburg vom 29 mai
2001 tvfandung nach Inka von Daniel
Böcking brickit TG 56 wird am Freitag
den Fernseher nicht einschalten dann
fandet das ZDF um 20:15 Uhr bei
Aktenzeichen XY ungelöst nach ihrer
Tochter die Mutter aus rahstedt sie ist
bald am Ende mit ihrer Kraft sie könnte
die tv-szenen nicht ertragen vor neun
Monaten verschwand ihre geliebte Tochter
Inka köntkes in Hannover Brigitte g die
ersten Wochen nach Inkas verschwinden
erlebte ich wie im Albtraum aber jetzt
sie schluckt atme tief sie weint das
Leben geht weiter dieser Satz tut weh
und ist leider auch so wahr die Mutter
muss sich um Inkas Versicherungen
kümmern um Steuern um Briefwechsel ohne
zu wissen ob ihr Kind überhaupt noch
lebt 5 Jahre nach Inkas verschwinden
macht der Fall
widerschlagzeilen denn ihr Mann hat
jetzt jede Hoffnung aufgegeben und so
steht in Bild Hannover am
12.082005 die Polizei hat 547 Spuren
erfolglos abgearbeitet den Fall längst
zu den Akten gelegt jetzt gibt auch Mark
köntges die Suche nach Inka auf über die
Polizei ließ er mitteilen dass er die 20
000 Mark Belohnung die er demjenigen
zahlen wollte der Inka findet
zurückzieht aus persönlichen Gründen der
promovierte Physiker wohnt jetzt in
Hameln fand dort eine neue Liebe im
September ließ er sich in Abwesenheit
seiner Frau scheiden die vermisste hat
drei mon Zeit dagegen Einspruch zu
erheben im Dezember will mark könkes
seine neue Partnerin heiraten im Sommer
darauf verschwinden in Hannover die
37-Jährige Karin gauke und ihre 7 Monate
alte Tochter Kara kurzzeitig sind
Öffentlichkeit und Ermittler in diesen
Wochen des Jahres 2006 alarmiert gibt es
vielleicht einen Zusammenhang hat ein
Mörder nicht nur in Kön sondern
auch Tochter ermordet die Spur muss man
sagen bringt leider nichts der Fall
gauke wird später gelöst der Ehemann
verurteilt aber in Sachen Inka nichts
neues das Spiel wiederholt sich als im
Frühjahr 2007 der Schädel einer Frau im
Harz gefunden wird der macht
Schlagzeilen hat aber nichts mit dem
Fall köntkis zu tun noch einmal
beschäftigt in später die Öffentlichkeit
Hamburger Morgenpost
1072 12 für Tod erklärt Inka könkes
spurlos verschwunden Hamburgerin fuhr
zur Arbeit und wurde nie wieder gesehen
jetzt will ihre Familie endgültig
Abschied nehmen Zwillingsschwester Birke
41 hat beim Amtsgericht Hannover einen
Antrag gestellt Inka für Tod zu erklären
das Verfahren ist möglich weil die
Mindestfrist von 10 Jahren verstr ist
natürlich würde das inkers Verschwinden
nicht aufklären aber es gibt uns die
Chance endlich einen Schlussstrich zu
ziehen sagt Vater Eike sollte sich bis
zum 20 September dieses Jahres niemand
beim Amtsgericht Hannover Zimmer 3263
melden wird Inka köntkes für Tod erklärt
für ihre Familie wäre es zumindest ein
kleiner Erfolg im Kampf gegen die
unerträgliche Ungewissheit soweit dieser
Artikel nach und nach wurden also alle
Akten geschlossen aber was ist mit Inka
köntges passiert man kann im
wesentlichen drei Theorien diskutieren
erstens der Unbekannte Mörder Inka wurde
in der Eilenriede überfallen und
verschleppt vielleicht tötete der Täter
sie vor Ort vielleicht verschleppte er
sie aber auch und ermordete Sie später
an einem anderen Ort aber wie soll all
das um diese Tageszeit unbemerkt
geklappt haben und wieso gab es trotz
großflächiger suche keinerlei Spuren im
Wald wo ist die Leiche Möglichkeit 2 der
Täter aus dem Umfeld Inka trifft auf dem
Arbeitsweg jemanden den sie kennt
jemanden der es aus irgendeinem Grund
einem vielleicht leidenschaftlichen
Motiv auf sie abgesehen hat hatte sie
einen eifersüchtigen Liebhaber einen
Verehrer aus der Kirchengemeinde für
nichts davon gibt es Spuren oder gar
Beweise das könnte für die dritte
Möglichkeit sprechen die geplante Flucht
will schon lange aus ihrem Leben
ausbrechen aus dem engen Umfeld der
Kirchengemeinde vielleicht hat sich ihre
junge Ehe schon in den ersten Wochen als
Fehlentscheidung erwiesen als
Beziehungshölle sie plant ihr
Verschwinden weiß schon wo es hingeht um
eine rätselhafte verwirrende Spur zu
legen fragt sie unter anderem im Wald
einen zufälligen Zeugen nach dem Weg für
einen handfesten Ehekrach muss man sagen
gibt es zwar keine Indizien aber
tatsächlich beschrieben bekannte Inka in
den letzten Wochen vor ihrem
Verschwinden als angeschlagen und
gestresst und genervt Inka wäre nicht
die erste die aus ihrem Leben ausbricht
aber würde sie ihre Eltern und ihre
Zwillingsschwester so leiden lassen und
so im Ungewissen lassen fest steht nicht
nur in Inkas Leben spielte der Glaube
eine wichtige Rolle sondern auch in dem
ihrer Eltern und so hörte Bildreporter
Daniel Böcking viele Jahre nach seinem
ersten Besuch bei Mutter Brig GB in
Hamburg noch einmal von ihr ja das hat
tatsächlich sehr sehr viel mit dem
Glauben zu tun weil es mir auch so
gegangen ist dass ich Jahre später und
das hatte nichts mehr mit dem Fall
köntkes zu tun zum Glauben gefunden habe
und durfte dann sogar zwei Bücher
darüber schreiben und eins davon hat
anscheinend die Mutter von Inka
irgendwann mal gelesen und daraufhin
schrieb sie mich dann viele viele Jahre
später noch mal an um mir zu sagen dass
ihr auch dieses Gespräch damals viel
bedeutet hätte und dass ich sie
vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen besser
verstehen könnte wie sie damals reagiert
hat oder wie sie mit der Situation
umgegangen ist und das hat mich
natürlich sehr im Inneren getroffen weil
damals hatte ich überhaupt kein
Verständnis dafür und ich muss auch
sagen dass ist natürlich schwierig finde
jetzt mit 20 Jahren Abstand noch mal zu
bewerten wie das damals war vielleicht
hat die Mutter das ganze Gespräch
komplett anders wahrgenommen aber ich
aus meiner persönlichen Perspektive kann
halt sagen wenn ich so etwas danach das
war damals schon weit über 15 Jahre her
oder sowasas plötzlich noch mal trifft
mit einer E-Mail dass mich das natürlich
auch persönlich noch mal sehr bewegt hat
und noch mal auf gedankenreisen
geschickt hat das war unser Fall für
heute wir hoffen Ihr seid auch beim
nächsten Mal wieder dabei euer Stefan
und euer
merk